foreign
thousands of students from all over the
world hope to study in Nations other
than their own for a variety of reasons
many of them cite job advancement higher
pay and lifestyle changes as the reasons
for traveling to foreign countries
however making this decision of studying
abroad is not that easy you'll have to
carry out thorough research about which
country is best suited for you and what
prospects it has to offer and to assist
you with that we bring you this video on
best countries to study abroad in this
session we'll explore the factors that
are commonly referred to while choosing
the country to study abroad and after
that we'll look at the top four
countries for abroad education so make
sure you stay back until the end of this
video
first let's dive into the parameters for
selecting the best country for studying
abroad
education is the greatest transforming
instrument in the world shaping not just
individuals but also societies no matter
in which corner of the world we live in
education should be given Prime
importance as it help us gain new
knowledge progress in life and build a
better world for tomorrow education also
makes us think and behave more
rationally though education is
acknowledged and valued in Many Nations
throughout the world a few countries
stand out if we attempt to focus on what
constitutes the finest education system
in the world their education systems are
not only of great quality but many of
them also have certain distinguishing
features that set them apart for example
the United States is one of the most
popular destinations for students
worldwide the reason is high quality
education world-class faculty and
cutting-edge infrastructure and
Facilities according to Qs World
university ranking report the United
States is considered to have better
educational System since 28 universities
from this country rank among the top
hundred universities globally
the United Kingdom is the second best
country for Quality education 16
universities from United Kingdom rank in
top 100 universities worldwide the
institutions from the UK hold strong
brand identity University of Oxford
University of Cambridge Imperial College
of London University of Edinburgh London
School of economics and political
sciences hold a strong value in
education industry
the next factor that matters a lot is
the student acceptance rate this is one
of the foremost concern for students who
wish to study abroad everyone faces the
difficulty of assimilating into a
completely different environment culture
traditions and Customs despite putting
in a ton of efforts to become acquainted
with the culture acceptance remains a
major goal for individuals in recent
times students have become little
skeptical about countries such as
Australia UK and Italy the reason behind
this is the past event of racism and
anti-migrant sentiments according to a
survey done by human rights Department
in Australia 85 percent of respondents
believe that racism is the biggest
current issue in Australia you can
observe the same scenario in United
Kingdom as well events like brexit and
anti-migrant sentiment in UK have led to
apprehensiveness among students studying
abroad besides that students are wary of
countries such as France even though it
is regarded as a top study destination
since the major university programs in
this country are taught in French
language the next and most important
factor in selecting a country to study
abroad is budget students on a tight
budget always prioritize Germany but it
is not simple to get into any of the
public universities because competition
is fierce furthermore Nordic countries
are regarded as economical study
location for International students
countries such as Norway and Poland are
available to everyone irrespective of
their nationality
students will only have to pay for a
specialized courses in these countries
whereas there is no tuition fee in
Germany if you get selected by a public
university
finally the last factor to look into is
return on investment return on
investment is simple ratio that divides
the net profit or loss from an
investment by its cost because it is
expressed as a percentage you can
compare the effectiveness or
profitability of your investment in this
scenario one way to look at Roi is the
amount of time it takes to recoup your
investment in education
for Masters European institutions
generally have one year master's degree
whereas U.S institutions have two years
master's degree it is definitely less
expensive to study in Europe in the
present scenario Germany for example
should be the ideal choice if one is
looking at getting the maximum return on
his investment because Germany provides
pre-education even for international
students one more country that has
recently become very popular is Island
Ireland offers a one-year program and
has become the European capital of I.T
inspiring many students to look at the
country for higher education
to emphasize this point further consider
this scenario for MBA students doing a
one-year European MBA would get more
return for their bucks as they have
spent only one year courses fee plus
potential employment loss this is the
reason why inside MBA is rated the
highest on value for money versus other
prestigious schools like Harvard or
Stanford on that note let's discover the
top four countries for pursuing abroad
education based on the factors we have
just discovered
the fourth country on our list is
Australia Australia promotes Innovation
creativity and independent thinking
throughout its universities
International students in Australia
highlight that their education is
challenging fun and rewarding besides
that eight universities out of 39
Australian universities rank among top
100 institutes globally Australian
National University University of
Melbourne University of Sydney
University of New South Wales and
University of Queensland are the top
five universities in Australia now let's
talk about why we have listed Australia
at the fourth position the main reason
behind that is the budget associated
with education in Australia
the average tuition fee for
undergraduate programs in Australia is
around 24 000 Australian dollars which
turns out to be almost 18 048 US Dollars
similarly if you are looking to pursue a
postgraduate degree in Australia then
the average tuition cost is around 32
000 Australian dollars that's not the
end of expenses you'll have to think
about living expenses as well the
average monthly living expense in
Australia for one person is 3 800
Australian dollars if you convert this
number into U.S dollars it becomes
almost 3 000 USD that is a lot of money
aside from that here is an interesting
fact the cost of living in Australia is
almost 15 percent greater than the
America it ranks 10th among the most
expensive countries to live in living
both UK and USA behind
the reserve funds you'll have to keep in
a closed bank account are almost 21 000
Australian dollars which represents you
have the financial means to cover at
least one year's educational expenses in
Australia budget wise this is not the
ideal choice for students with financial
restrictions that is the reason why we
have Australia as the fourth contender
next up on our list is United Kingdom
as mentioned earlier 16 universities in
UK rank among top Global universities
the University of Oxford University of
Cambridge Imperial College London are
the top universities that rank among top
10 Global universities besides that
these colleges have been around since
the Middle Ages bearing a significant
history of world education that is why
the United Kingdom has been ranked
number one globally for the quality of
education and Facilities the UK has the
best educational system globally
comprised of undergraduate postgraduate
and doctoral degrees
ug courses are designed to help Learners
gain practical exposure after three
years of undergraduate courses Learners
can pursue a master's degree the
one-year Master's course offer more
in-depth study for particular subject
that makes Learners eligible for
high-paying jobs and promotions the next
factor is budget as you must know the UK
is one of the most expensive countries
to live in the tuition fee in UK lie
around an average of 13 000 50 euros
whereas living expenses are around 10
308 Euros that means the block account
fund for a Year's expense will be the
sum of both these figures which turns
out to be almost 26 000 US Dollars the
country that holds second rank on our
list is United States according to the
report of education.com the United
States has been ranked second worldwide
for the quality of Education
MIT Stanford Harvard the University of
Chicago and the University of
Pennsylvania are the top five American
universities ranking among the top 15
institutions globally
for decades the U.S has reigned Supreme
as the world's most popular study abroad
destination the country's prestigious
institutions dominate Global University
rankings attracting students from across
the world with an appetite for academic
excellence
according to the project Atlas report
1.2 million plus International students
reside in United States the reason
behind that is the immigration policies
of country and cultural Acceptance in
the U.S International students can stay
and work for 12 months after completing
their studies further students who go
for stem education this duration is 24
months Indians are the largest
beneficiary for H-1B visas more than 60
percent of these visas are issued to the
Indian Community which is a great deal
for the Indian Community
now coming to the budget to study in
America the living expenses and tuition
fee are quite higher here you'll have to
pay around 35 331 US Dollars on average
to get into the university program also
the average living cost is around 18 000
US Dollars which is quite high too
however many students prefer the USA
since the job opportunities here are
quite lucrative and as high as you can
get many students cite that they
fulfilled their Education Loans within
two to three years of time span this
indicates High Returns on investment in
mediocre time
on that note let's move towards the
first country on our list Germany
Germany has always been among the top
Global destinations for students across
the globe because the german-speaking
people have been an Inseparable part of
world's greatest invention in both Arts
and Sciences practically every academic
area has a long and exceptional Heritage
of success stories here in Germany
furthermore Germany has abolished all
tuition cost for both National and
international students making education
more accessible
the top five public institutions
offering pre-education in Germany a
Technical University of Munich
University of Heidelberg LMU Munich free
University Berlin and Humboldt
University there are 430 plus public
universities in Germany that offer
education at no cost these universities
will only charge you approximately 500
to 600 euros per semester for
administrative expenditure typically
referred to as semester contributions
these speeds cover contribution charges
travel expenses and student union fees
the next benefit of Germany as a study
destination is the lower block funds
these funds serve as proof that you have
the financial means to cover at least
one year's living expenses since there
is no tuition fee in Germany this amount
is lower you'll just have to show the
amount summing up your one-year living
expenses such as rent internet food Etc
considering inflation the mandatory
amount required in the block account for
studying in Germany as of January 1 2022
its Euros 10 332 for an entire year or
Euros 861 for a month candidate would
have to keep a little more than the said
amount as the bank could Levi a service
charge on the student opening block
account in Germany however you need not
to worry about the charges because
German law allows you to work for 20
hours a week and almost 120 full days in
a year you'll not require any type of
approval for this you can automatically
work for 20 hours a week the moment you
have National visa for a student plus a
remuneration is a beneficiary Factor
here you'll get 15 euros per hour of
your work also the master's program in
Germany are typically for one year which
means you'll only have to pay fees for
one year and later by launching and
acing your job hunt you can start
earning as well as fulfilling your
educational loans as you might know
Germany is the fourth largest economy in
the world after United States China and
Japan also it is the largest economy in
Eastern Europe continent because of that
there are plenty of jobs available for
international students with technical
expertise however to get the jobs you
you are required to have German language
proficiency be one level of language
proficiency is bare minimum before you
can look out for permanent job let's
talk about sectors that produce maximum
job opportunities in Germany the first
one is information technology as you
know the world is gravitating towards
complete virtualization since the covet
pandemic the requirement for it experts
in Germany has increased exponentially
according to the survey there are around
124 000 open jobs for ID Professionals
in Germany that's why it is at the top
of our list the next sector that
produces more jobs in Germany is
engineering particularly mechanical
engineering and automobile engineering
are the trail bridges that produce a
pool of job opportunities you can also
find abundant jobs related to
electronics Robotics and chemical
engineering sectors another sector that
has huge potential is Medical Science
Germany has always been a big
contributor to the global medical sector
so
you can definitely get jobs for
healthcare sector as well that's all we
have about the best countries to study
abroad however if you don't have the
required Capital support to launch your
International Journey we recommend you
to look out for Global PSW programs
available online
these programs can help you accelerate
your career in global market with the
least Financial requirements simple
learn offers one such Management program
in collaboration with IU Germany you can
now get access to the best that IU has
to offer study on campus build an
International Management career and get
an opportunity to work in Germany with
this master of Business Administration
MBA program in collaboration with IU
Germany and London South Bank University
lsba you can become a Global Management
industry leader furthermore after
successful completion of this course
you'll be able to launch a career in
German corporations with an 18-month
long post-study work visa here are few
highest paying job opportunities that
you can get in Germany after finishing
this accredited MBA program
the average base salary for finance
Professionals in Germany range around
almost 89 000 Euros which pan out to be
75 lakh rupees in India the best salary
for marketing professionals is almost 65
600 euros having an equivalence of 54
lakh Indian rupees the next MBA
specialization that is business
analytics also has fruitful salaries it
starts from 60 000 Euros the fourth one
is Operation and logistic management
profession
this profession can provide you with
salaries starting from a base pay of 72
000 Euros
and finally human resource Professionals
in Germany can earn from 50 000 Euros
having equivalence of 42 lakh Indian
rupees all these numbers mentioned above
are quite fruitful compared to the
salaries in other developing countries
so thinking about this program is
worthwhile that's all we have for today
thank you so much for watching this
video and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here